salut aujourd'hui je suis à aix en
provence on est en pleine tournée avec
gary there voici l'activité principale
d'un régisseur en tournée je propose des
voitures font rien lui dire parce qu'en
fait il n'a pas le permis et ne brisons
pas serré
alors on a commencé la tournée le 6
janvier à lille aujourd'hui chez avex en
provence pour ceux qui suivent la chaîne
depuis longtemps il ya un an jour pour
jour je fais des gens spectacle ici ça
résonne toujours autant sauf que la
différence par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est que vous êtes nombreux à
m'avoir découvert sur la chaîne à venir
découvrir le spectacle et je suis assez
surpris des discussions on a après le
spectacle ce qui revient le plus est que
vous ne vous attendiez pas à voir ça sur
scène et je me demande du coup ils
peuvent vous attendiez il ya un couple
hier soir donc mercredi soir c'est le
mec qui est venue avec sa mère et lui
avait dit bon tu vois c'est pas très
drôle mais c'est intéressant et je suis
d'accord c'est ça l'image que je renvoie
dans les vidéos et c'est normal c'est
vrai que je n'ai pas forcément d'humour
dans les vidéos mois pour faire de
l'humour
j'ai besoin d'être avec des personnes
j'ai besoin d'être en interaction
mais au moins ça m'a donné l'idée de me
dire à temps avant la vidéo de samedi
parce que je pense que je vais sortir
une vidéo samedi je vais faire celle-ci
rapidement pour dire en fait quelle est
la différence entre les vidéos et la
scène
alors d'abord peut-être un point commun
un des points communs c'est que en vidéo
j'essaie de vous transmettre des choses
et sur scène c'est pareil il ya des
choses que je transmets une différence
maintenant c'est que en vidéo quand je
mets la vidéo j'ai besoin d'attendre
quelques heures voire quelques jours
avant de savoir ce que vous en pensez
sur scène c'est immédiat si je dis une
blague qu'elle n'est pas drôle je sais
tout de suite par contre c'est le drôle
je le sais aussi dans les vidéos le
nombre d'abonnés même si j'ai conscience
que vous êtes des gens de l'autre côté
juste là ça reste aussi un nombre un
chiffre alors que dans un spectacle je
vous vois portes de vrai et on peut
échanger et je rencontre des gens
incroyables est formidable
hier soir j'ai vraiment rencontré
flavien flat bien qu'il me fait c'est
magnifique cadeau regardez j'ai dit si
je vous dis
on peut voir deux d'entre elles c'est de
la bière que le mec fait lui même la
bière d'aix-en-provence la couenne ma
taille on a l'idée 2 avec gary sur les 4
c'est un petit bijou dans le spectacle
c'est vrai que je fais beaucoup
participer le public mais attention
c'est que les personnes qui veulent je
ne force pas à qui que ce soit à faire
quoi que ce soit les personnes qui
veulent vraiment participer ce soir vous
pouvez le lever la main ça n'arrête
jamais sauf sur les gens bizarres je
vous repère à ce moment là voilà ces
pratiques non n'hésitez pas à l'asie
alors des fois oui c'est vrai par contre
dans le spectacle en essayant de vous
transmettre des choses j'utilise des
ternes et de technique
je sais déjà que c'est un homme qui l'a
écrit la sq en graphologie on a des
termes techniques
là par exemple je peux le dire le terme
technique c'est que c'est écrit comme un
cochon et nous les mecs ne mentons pas
on écrit très mal
ok et puis évidemment mon but c'est 2
vous bluffer avec des choses comme ça si
possible assez incroyable quoi néanmoins
l'homme qui a écrit ça il a écrit ça un
petit peu au dessus de la ligne en
dehors du cadre
et ça c'est un signe d'intelligence et
de vivacité d'esprit
j'aime bien parce que l'âge et jean
marie et cédric qui font le coup tu veux
pas de l'excès mais le monsieur est mort
d'alice il a deviné et d'une manière
générale durant les 1h30 1h40 que durant
le spectacle
je vais le découvrir le mental est ce
une sous toutes ses formes parfois c'est
vous qui vous au tome le fait à
découvrir quelque chose en même temps
que moi et puis je vous fais partager un
petit peu plus ma vie mon humour qui je
crois est universel puisque je me suis
aperçu d'un truc très drôle dans les
annuaires ça marche avec tous les
départements et toutes les années si
vous regardez bien un annuaire à chaque
page on fait pas attention la première
fois mais regarder à chaque fois chaque
page
il a systématiquement trois colonnes
partagent chaque fois c'est le mort de
mentalist tu peux pas comprendre
chacun ses blagues c'est tout un chacun
ses blagues bref d'être sur scène avec
vous c'est aussi une manière de créer
des liens entre nous encore plus fort
que les commentaires ou les vidéos des
fois un petit peu trop fort a pas se
mentir appuie bien faut pas que je
puisse voir alors faut pas que je puisse
voir maxime par contre faut que je
puisse entendre
l'idée c'est pas de boucher tous les
trous juste le vieux sage et puis
évidemment à la fin du spectacle qu'on
se rencontre en général durant une heure
et demie la première date le 6 janvier
j'avais passé 3h40 de dédicaces ceux qui
étaient là s'en souviennent donc une
heure et demie sur scène 3h40 en
dédicace on a vite fait le calcul avant
la fin de la tournée jal est décédé si
vous vous avez déjà vu le spectacle
n'hésitez pas à le dire dans les
commentaires dites moi ce que vous avez
pensé vraiment n'hésitez pas ça fait
plaisir d'avoir un retour et puis pour
ceux qui veulent venir il ya toutes les
dates sur le site internet un tous les
dix mois prochain je fais je fais quatre
représentations à toulon 2e à versailles
c'est la date la plus proche de paris
six dates à grenoble et puis après sur
les autres - il y aura encore d'autres
villes bordeaux que c'était rien tout
seul site internet j'espère avoir un peu
plus répondu à cette question qu'ils
allaient partout aussi dans les
commentaires de caisse qui a dans ce
spectacle donc grosso modo le mentalisme
c'est le fond l'humour c'est la france
est un one man show de mentalisme si
cette vidéo vous a plu comme d'habitude
vous pouvez mettre à bron like et vous
abonner et rendez vous sûrement samedi
matin ciao
[Musique]